Çeviri: Melike Karasu
Gözden geçirme: Yunus ASIK
Köprüyü geçmek konusu bana yollandığında,
bu konuda ne söylenebilir
diye hiç düşünmeden
köprünün sözlerden kurulmuş
bir dil olduğuna dair
zaten çok önceden bildiğim bir—
kendimi düşünmeye bile zorlamadan aklıma
gelen ilk köprünün dil olduğunun
farkına vardım.
Bu da herhâlde dille hayatını kazanan,
sözlerle hayatını kazanan birisi için
çok şaşırtıcı olmasa gerek.
Çocukken bize okullarda Türkiye’nin
doğu ile batı arasında bir
köprü olduğu öğretildi.
O zamanlar doğu ile batıyı,
güneşin doğup battığı yönler
olarak biliyorduk.
Öyle sanıyordum.
Daha sonra doğu ile batının
aslında değerlerinin birbirinden
çok farklı iki insan uygarlığını
işaret ettiğini öğrenecektim.
Yine ilkokulda özellikle bizim kuşaklarda
Orta Atlas denilen bir atlas
okullarda okutulurdu.
Ben seyahat etmeye çok meraklı
çocuklardan biriydim.
Ödevlerimi bırakır, Orta Atlas'ta
gözümü kapatır,
herhangi bir noktaya
parmağımı basardım
ve o neresi çıkıyorsa oraya
seyahat etmeye başlardım.
O zaman internet yoktu, eğer İzlanda
ya da İspanya çıkmışsa
onu gidip çocuk ansiklopedisi,
resimli bilgiden arar,
onun üzerine hayaller kurardım.
Bir süre sonra ödevimi yapmamış ama
bir ansiklopedinin, Orta Atlas'ın başında
uyumuş olarak beni bulurlarmış.
Daha sonra Orta Atlas'ta benim için
en önemli Türkiye’yle ilgili algı
hep bir köprü olduğu söylenen Türkiye’nin
doğu ile batı arasında,
aslında fiziken de bir köprüye
benzediğini keşfetmek oldu.
Çünkü muhtemelen ortak bir
kıtadan parçalanarak
bazı tektonik hareketlerle parçalanarak
ortaya çıkan Akdeniz adalarını
gözünüzün önüne getirirseniz
İber yarımadası, çizme şeklindeki İtalya,
sonra beş parmak şeklinde
Mora yarımadasına baktığınızda
dördüncü Akdeniz yarımadası olan
Türkiye’nin üzerinde bulunduğu
anakaranın, Anadolu yarımadasının
aslında bir köprüye de
benzediğini keşfedip
bu köprü meselesine çocukken
çok takmıştım.
Yani benim için çok olumlu bir kavramdı.
Dediğim gibi doğu ve batı medeniyetinin
ne olduğunu henüz bilmiyordum.
Ayrıca Anadolu yarımadasının da
bizim anneye, kadına çok değer veren
bir toplum olduğumuz için Ana Dolu olarak
bizim bu adı verdiğimizi sanıyordum.
Daha sonra biraz daha büyüdüğümde
bunun aslında Yunanca Anatoli,
güneşin doğduğu doğu yönünü
işaret ettiğini öğrenecektim.
Biraz yanılgılarla, düş kırıklarıyla
başlasa da
köprü benim için hep çok önemli oldu.
Ama köprü derken, medeniyetin, uygarlığın
en önemli araçlarından
ya da insanlığın en büyük buluşlarından
biri olduğunu iddia ederken
belki şöyle bir karşı tezle bana karşı
çıkanlar olacaktır.
İnsanlığın tekerliği, ateşi kontrol
edebilmeyi,
ne bileyim aşıları, antibiyotiği,
teleskobu, mikroskobu bulması
ya da uzaya gidecek araçları, interneti
icadı yanında,
köprünün ne manası var, nedir ki
diyebilir bazılarınız.
Bence bütün bu buluşlar içinde
köprü olmazsa olmazdır.
Çünkü köprü nedir diye
demin de konuşuldu.
Köprü; aslında en az iki şey
arasındaki yoldur.
Bu iki şey; iki element olabilir,
iki mekân olabilir,
iki konu olabilir, iki ülke olabilir
veya iki kalp, iki gönül, iki insan,
iki can olabilir.
Ama tabii bizim aklımıza köprü deyince
somut olarak ya ağaçtan yani
ahşaptan yapılmış
ya da bildiğimiz inşaat malzemesinden
yapılmış köprüler gelebilir.
Oysa ki köprü mecaza yani metaforik
kullanıma çok açık bir kavramdır.
Bu yüzden köprünün medeniyetler
üzerinde çok büyük önemi vardır.
Biraz daha açabilmek için son yıllarda
hem ülkemizde hem de dünyada
çok okunan, çok kıymetli bir kitaptan
bahsetmek istiyorum.
Çünkü oradan bir iki öneriyle tezimi
kuvvetlendirmeye çalışacağım.
Noah Harari adlı bir antropologun
bizde de çok okunan bir kitabı var,
Sapiens; İnsan Türünün Kısa Bir
Tarihi adlı bir kitap.
Çoğunuzun da okuduğunu
düşündüğüm bir kitap.
Orada Harari aslında sanki
canlı yayındaymış gibi,
antropolojik yıllara yani tarih öncesi
zamana gidip
bize orada olup bitenleri anlatıyor.
Galiba en güzel tarafı da diğer
antropolojik kitaplardan
en güzel, farklı tarafı da
çok iyi bir hikâyeci olması.
Ve bizi alıp sanki o zamanın içine
götürüyor olması.
Anlattığı hikâyelerde hep neden bizim,
hepimizin, Norveç’te yaşayanların,
bu salonda olanların ya da Afrika’daki
şu anda modern insanın
son tür olan Homo Sapiens'in
nasıl olup da diğer hayvanlara ve
kendisine en çok benzeyen insan türü
olan Homo Neanderthal'lere
nasıl olup da galip geldiğini,
neden bizim hâlâ hayatta olup
onların olmadığını araştırıyor.
Bulduğu birçok ipucu var, tabii
bunları hem antropoloji,
hem arkeoloji, hem de
moleküler biyolojiden
yararlanarak kanıtları ortaya koyuyor.
Şöyle bir örnek veriyor;
elbette bütün canlıların kendi
arasında iletişim kurduğu
yani köprüsü olan dil var.
Ama bir tek Homo Sapiens'in yarattığı
özgün dil, bu iletişimi
çok kolaylaştırıyor.
İletişim olmasaydı yani insan denen
canlının kendine özgün yarattığı
bu dil olmasaydı, --
şu anda bizim iletişim kurduğumuz
dil, hangi kültüre aitse
onun adını alıyor biliyorsunuz--
hiçbir medeniyet olmazdı ve insanlık
devam edemez Homo Sapiens türü diyor.
Ve şöyle bir örnek veriyor;
şu anda hepimiz 30.000 kişilik
bir stadyum düşünelim
ve bu stadyumun önünde de
30.000 kişi var.
Bu insanlar eğer bir holigan
yoksa ortada, gayet kontrollü
bir şekilde turnikelerden geçip
yerlerine oturuyorlar stadda,
işte buraya geldiğimiz gibi hepimizin.
Ve insan hayalinin yarattığı bir maçı
gene insan hayalinin kurduğu zaman,
saat ve kurallarla izliyorlar.
Daha sonra maç bittiğinde
gene holigan yoksa
o insanlar turnikelerden
çıkıp dağılıyorlar.
Şimdi diyor ki Harari, bence çok
yerinde bir tespitle,
bu kadar organize bir mobilizasyonu,
hareketi başka hiçbir canlı yapamıyor.
Diyeceksiniz ki arılar ve sinekler var,
ya da karıncalar var.
Onlar tamamen genetik kodlarıyla
hareket ediyorlar.
Oysa insan bulunduğu yere göre
oyunu kuruyor
ve kontrollü bir şekilde organize
oluyor ve mobilize oluyor.
Bir tane de bu anlattığı
örneğin arkasından
çok hoş bir sorusu var okura.
Eğer diyor en akıllı hayvan olan
şempanzeleri,
30.000 tane şempanzeyi bu stada
koysaydınız ne olurdu.
Herhalde dehşetengiz bir şey olurdu,
düşünmesi bile çok zor geliyor bana.
O yüzden ister kanıtlara bakın ister
kendi aklınızla yola çıkın,
gerçekten insanın en büyük,
medeniyetle ilgili
başardığı en büyük, belki de ilk
uygarlık köprüsü dil.
Dil olmadan birbirimizle
iletişim kuramıyoruz
Harari’den sonra bahsetmek istediğim
bir yazar daha var,
bu gerçekten edebiyatçı.
Edebiyat dünyasının sihirbazı,
bilgesi olmuş birisi,
Ursula Le Guin, belki okumuşsunuzdur.
Onun bizim dilimize
Kadınlar, Ejderhalar ve Rüyalar
diye çevrilmiş bir deneme kitabı var.
Küçük bir mücevher kutusu adeta o kitap.
Okumaya başladığınızda
başucunuzdan ayıramazsınız.
O kitapta çuval kuramı ve kurgu diye,
Türkçe'ye böyle çevrilmiş --
bir deneme var.
O deneme gerçekten çok önemli.
Çuval dediği aslında çanta, file --
veya evet çuvalı niye öyle çevirdiklerini
ben doğrusu pek anlayamadım.
Ursula Le Guin orada bize uygarlığın,
insanlık uygarlığının, insanlığın
yarattığı uygarlığın
aslında bize hep anlatılmaya
çalışıldığı gibi
alfa erkek modeli üzerinden olmadığını,
bunun dişi zekâ ile ortaya çıktığını
anlatmaya çalışıyor.
Buna örnek olarak da birçoğunuzun bildiği,
artık kült filme dönüşmüş olan
Arthur C. Clarke’ın romanından
uyarlanan Stanley Kubrick’in
2001 Space Odyssey; Uzay Macerası
diye çevrildi Türkçe'ye,
o filmi hatırlarsanız, çok etkileyici
ve hâlâ da kült bir sahnesi vardır.
İşte en zeki hayvan olan şempanze
veya orangutan
insan kemiklerini kırmaya çalışmaktadır.
İçlerinden bir kemik havaya sıçrar
ve bir vals eşliğinde dönerek
bir süre sonra da bir uzay mekiğine gider.
Ursula Le Guin diyor ki hiç üşenmeden,
bu diyor hiç doğru bir teori değil
medeniyet için,
öyle kemikle falan bizi uyutmayın.
Aslında bir torba ile başladı
bütün medeniyet diyor.
Ve şöyle anlatıyor,
çok büyük ve doğuştan hikâyeci olduğu için
sizi hemen alıyor ve bir yazı öncesi
mağaraya götürüyor tarih içinde.
Bu mağarada Om, Omom ve Omomom
adlı 3 kişilik bir aileden bahsediyor;
anne, baba ve çocuk.
Henüz bir dil gelişmediği için
tam manasıyla
hepimizin anlayabileceği
ortak bir dil yaratıyor.
Zaten çok ünlüdür kitaplarında
- biliyorsunuz,
bilim kurguda hep diller yaratan
bir kadındır.
Bu aile, üçlü aile normalde otları,
bitkileri, meyveleri yiyerek yaşıyor,
belki kabuklu küçük hayvanları.
Fakat hava şartları kötü olduğunda
o yiyecekleri alıp
eve yani mağaralarına getirecek
hiçbir kapları yok.
Bunun üzerine özellikle hastalandıklarında
ve kötü hava şartlarında aç kalıyorlar.
Aç kalmak demek de zaten
türün devamını
engelleyecek çok tehlikeli bir şey.
Bunun üzerine Omom, yani ailenin
kadını, dişi olan
ya saçlarından belki de kenevirden
belki de yapraklardan
bir torba örmeye başlıyor.
Bu torba aslında, bugün burada
bir kısmını
burada veya dünyanın bir yerinde
yaşadığımız insanlık medeniyetinin,
insanın kurduğu uygarlığın temelinde
yatan ana köprüdür diyor.
Çünkü o torbayla dışarıdan
ot ya da yiyecek toplamaya giden kimse
anne ya da baba dönerken mağaraya
sadece otla ya da yiyecekle dönmüyor,
bu torbanın içinde
hikâyesini de getiriyor.
Dünyayı hikâyeler değiştirmiştir diyor.
Uygarlık tamamen o torbaya ve
o torbanın içindeki hayallere, kurguya,
insanın kurgu yapabilmesine,
bu kurguyu dile getirip ileriye taşıması
ve bunları da geleceğe kaydederek,
bu bilgileri gelecek
kuşaklara taşıyabilmesi,
insanın Neanderthal'den bile üste çıkıp ki
-- Neanderthal'den bile dememin sebebi;
Homo Sapiens'e göre
daha büyük bir beyni var,
kasları daha güçlü ve soğuğa
daha dayanıklı --
Homo Sapiens buna rağmen galip geliyor.
Onun içinde farklı teoriler var,
galip mi geldi, yoksa kaynaştı mı
genlerimiz onlarla, bilmiyorum.
Tabii bu hikâyeyle geri dönen Omom,
getirdiği yiyecekleri bırakırken,
diyelim ki yolda karşısına bir kuş çıktı
ve o kuştan ürktü kaçtı.
Döndüğünde şöyle anlatıyor:
“Karşıma dev bir kanatlarıyla
ejderha çıkmıştı.
Hemen geçtim, kılıcımı çektim”
– artık sopası mı ne varsa
“Onunla savaştım.
Bu gördüğün kollarımdaki kanlar”
– bakıyoruz çizik falan,
"Hepsi ondan."
Başlıyor hikâye.
İlk mitoloji böyle başlıyor.
Ve hikâyelere, kahramanlara ihtiyacımız,
aidiyetimiz böyle doğuyor.
Bana çok uygun geliyor bütün
bu anlatılanlar.
Kısa bir sürede, başka Dante’den de
örneklerim vardı ama zamanım çok kısalmış,
onun için asıl söylemek istediğime
gelmek istiyorum.
Hepimizin bir hikâyesi var.
Bu salonda oturan hepimizin.
Dışarıda rastladığımız genç yaşlı,
yoksul zengin hiç fark etmiyor,
hepimizin hikâyesi var.
Köprü, bu hikâyeleri
birbirimizle değiştirmek,
birbirimize aktarmakla kuruluyor.
Yani diyalog.
Diyalog çok önemli,
bugün belki en çok dünyanın
ihtiyacı olan şey diyalog.
Çünkü barışçıl yoldan
dünyanın yeniden düzenli bir şekilde
yani bugün yaşadığımız
iklim sorunlarından,
göç sorunlarına,
terör sorunlarına kadar,
dünyanın boğazına kadar battığı sorunlara
çözüm bulmak istiyorsak bu
köprüleri, diyaloğu
mutlaka yeniden kurmamız gerekiyor.
Hepimizin hikâyelerini birbirimize
anlatmamız
zaten bir düşünce özgürlüğü işidir.
Kendi otosansürümüzü kaldırıp
birbirimize hikâyelerimizi
anlattığımız sürece
bu köprü devam edecek.
En tehlikelisi bu köprünün kopuk olması,
kırılması, yıkılması.
Yani sen şu ırktansın, şu dindensin,
şu mezheptensin, şu cinsiyettensin diye
birbirimizi ayırıp
hikâyelerimizi kendi içimizde
anlattığımızda, köprüler kopuyor.
En tehlikelisi o.
Galiba şu anda biraz öyle bir durumdayız.
O yüzden köprüyü geçmenin
bu manada
önemli bir tema olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Yılanı deliğinden çıkaran tatlı dilin,
kemiği de yok.
Yani her yere dönebilir,
her türlü şeyi söyleyebilir.
Ama en güzeli herhâlde
dille kurulacak öyküleri
birbirimize anlatmak.
Ve birlikte birbirimizin hikâyelerini
dinlemeye açık olmak.
Diyalog yolunu açmak.
Köprülere devam etmek.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkışlar)